Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Good morning!
Just in case you weren't aware, today Ruffians, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our 46th episode!
BAU BAU!
Wow, for Ruffians who are joining us today for the first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
What?
Mococo, you kinda took a big breath there, didn't you?
I was on time, you were not.
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
A brand new week, a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning.
Well,
Has there been another Pero Sighting?
I don't know.
Ruffians!
De-den!
The disappearance of Pero.
It'll be okay, it'll be okay, right?
But Pero's Pero, right?
It'll be okay, it'll be okay.
Right!
Don't worry about it.
More importantly!
We had some fun this weekend, Ruffians!
We did!
This weekend, we made our first appearance at Anime Embrace!
Yeah!
Together with all of you, Advent!
Thank you!
Thank you, Ruffians, for being there to see us!
You know, it was a really fun experience.
On Saturday, we had a
Panel bright and early.
It definitely was a busy weekend, right?
We had the panel first thing in the morning on Saturday.
We had a quiz on the knowledge of New York.
Right!
Together with Abyss.
Ruffians, for those of you that couldn't be there.
How much do you think we knew about New York?
Were you impressed?
Did so well.
Are you sure?
Oh, at Anime NYC maybe?
Maybe not.
Maybe not so much the quiz.
New York knowledge.
Nothing.
We quickly realized that we didn't really learn that much from Sakura Wars either.
We didn't really know much.
Then we both had to do the Batsu game.
But I don't think Advent did that great to begin with.
It's okay.
Lower end average.
Yeah.
Maybe not
But after that, we had our first live performance at the hololive booth where we did a Rock n' Rawr Party Mini!
Yeah!
Look at all the Ruffians!
Yeah, and even though it was a Rock n' Rawr Party Mini, it wasn't really that many.
No.
No, it wasn't that many.
We kind of went over our time by an extra half hour.
It was supposed to be half an hour, but it went a bit longer.
It was just too much fun, you know?
We could hear you BAU BAUing and shouting.
See you shouting.
Was that amazing?
That amazing!
And waving our penlights around too!
So many pink and blue penlights!
Thank you!
We're really happy!
We're really glad that you were there and able to participate virtually through VRChat too!
It looked like you were having lots of fun there.
We got to see all the screenshots on Twitter.
Fun.
You're being silly, huh?
Because that was fun.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
Well, if it was fun, it was fun.
Uh-huh.
But, you know, we also ended off the weekend with another appearance of the group.
We did an early morning Q&A time.
And, you know, it was just... It was so nice being able to chat face-to-face with you.
Answer some of those burning questions you had, too.
It was just... We had such a good time.
We hope you did too, Ruffians, okay?
But!
We hope that we can make even more appearances at events close to you.
You know, be able to meet as many Ruffians as possible!
Also, we uploaded a small video from our Rawr Party.
We need to tweet it too!
So...
If you're curious as to what it kinda look like, like New York, you know, more than just this, what the BAU BAU sound is like and everything, please check it out, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Anime NYC!
I'd really like to be able to go to more places and meet, visit the Ruffians, you know?
Visit Ruffians, meet more Ruffians!
I'd like to be able to talk more closely, too, you know?
FUWAMOCO likes to go meet you!
You'll BAU BAU lots for us, right?
Please BAU BAU lots for us, okay?
BAU BAU!
It was a fun but busy busy weekend, huh?
Wow, tomorrow... Tomorrow is a big day!
We're having our first birthday girl.
And that birthday girl is Nobisai!
Birthday, Moco-chan?
A birthday.
A birthday?
Yes.
Yeah, Nerissa's gonna be having a special celebration too.
Starting at 5pm P.T.I.!
At 10am JST.
And it's gonna have some special announcements too.
Let's all be there to celebrate her special day, okay?
Yeah!
Nerissa November?
Yeah.
No.
I don't believe in birthday months.
That's true.
Her birthday's only tomorrow.
Yes, it's a day.
Ready for hours.
Not a minute more.
Yeah.
But as for a gift, I think we might have figured something out, right Moco-chan?
I don't know.
I don't know, I don't want the Ruffians to get upset or anything.
What?
What kind?
I think you have the same gift, right Moco-chan?
Ruffians, what kind of gifts are you thinking of?
Pantsu.
What?
No, Nerissa doesn't even need anything like that in the first place.
She doesn't.
We also wanted to say, we're not going to take that suggestion.
No way.
Well, we hope that you look forward to her birthday celebration as much as we are, okay?
Of course, you can find it on Nerissa's channel, okay?
I don't think she has the waiting room up here.
She's gonna make us wait in anticipation.
BAU BAU!
Happy birthday!
Birthday?
BAU BAU!
Wow, there's also been some really cool new music released!
Ruffians.
Just yesterday, Berry-senpai and Korone-senpai released an original song!
It's called "Bite Kamu Bite".
That's a really cute and catchy song.
It's filled with lots of WAN WAN WAN and CHU CHU CHU.
WAN WAN WAN CHU CHU CHU!
It's different from BAU BAU, not BAU BAU.
It's a WAN WAN WAN.
That's a dog.
Human dogs WAN WAN WAN.
That's what I was thinking.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians.
There's been a misunderstanding again.
But I sort of feel like it's not really our fault.
I don't know.
I don't know, I don't really get it.
I think, you know, Ruffians, I think there are a few of you who are thinking that, you know, FUWAMOCO might be releasing, like, an intense rap track to come sometime soon.
This is all because of our newest rivals.
Hi!
It's kind of your fault, Ruffians.
And that's why I don't think it's our fault, you know?
But, in case you don't know, during our Super Chat reading the other day, there was mention about how our Rock n' Rawr Party mini was just as fun as an ex-Japan or a Kendrick Lamar concert.
And, you know, I got a bit envious.
So, we named X Japan and Kendrick Lamar as our rivals.
Rivals!
You know, we want the Ruffians to have the most fun with us.
With us!
Yeah.
We're hungry puppies.
So, you know, it's not really that abnormal for us to have one or two or maybe a handful of healthy rivals.
Right!
What do you think, Ruffians?
It's good to have healthy rivals, you know.
Yeah.
Why?
Well, we know it's Japan, but... You know, we still don't really know who Kendrick Lamar is at all.
No... I couldn't remember his name, to be honest, at first.
I had to get a bit of a reminder.
But, uh... Yeah, but... You know, Ruffians, it... It seems like... Some of you... Quite a few of you are his fans.
You know?
But... Now...
Are you expecting us to do that thing where we battle him and say some grumpy things?
You know, I don't think we can really do that, but we are rivals!
Yeah!
Yeah, he's our rival, but... but...
Maybe, maybe, maybe can we turn the tables a little bit?
And instead, come meet us halfway and we could have a BAU BAU BATTLE!
BAU BAU BATTLE!
I'm the fastest BAU BAUer though.
What do you think, Ruffians?
Maybe that's a bit more fair, right?
BAU BAU BATTLE!
Right!
Do you think Kendrick Lamar could be a good BAU BAUer?
Moco-chan, how do you think you BAU- How do you think you combined with BAU BAU?
Maybe one day we'll find out!
Right!
Let's look forward to that day!
BAU BAU!
I'm probably not.
Probably not.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
We gotta practice.
We don't need to practice.
We are professional BAU BAUers.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU B
It's me, Pero.
As you can see, Ruffians, I'm on my vacation.
You know, I thought, I've been working hard, I deserve it, right?
You know, those thumbnails don't make themselves.
Let me take off my glasses here, then I can see a bit better now.
Well, did you forget about me?
No, right!
Because you keep on taking photos of me when I'm out and about!
Stop snitching on me to FUWAMOCO!
You wouldn't like that, would you?
Ha!
I'm a demon guard dog.
I'm their master.
I don't need to be kept to rack of or controlled.
But, I guess if I have to say, I am happy that because of you,
FUWAMOCO won't forget about me.
I'm an old dog now.
There are fun things going on.
They're more preoccupied with you Ruffians, huh?
Good.
But I'm happy they're still wondering a bit about me.
I guess.
Yeah.
I'll still be around, so keep an eye on me, okay?
Got it, Ruffians?
I have a bunch of things to do and knowledge to gather.
And then, then I can pass that on to FUWAMOCO.
So, if we cross paths, yeah, you better treat me right.
I'm to be revered.
Revered!
I'm the master!
I'm Pero!
Got it.
I'll get back to my drink then.
Pero out!
See you later, Ruffians!
That was strange.
Ruffians!
So I guess Pero was just on vacation.
I guess?
Maybe that's why we didn't see him.
Is he really actually doing anything there?
Is he actually gathering information?
He says he needs a vacation, but... I don't know what he's doing that much.
I don't know what it is.
It seems like, you know, maybe Pero's a little bit... Abyss?
Abyss?
Jealous?
Maybe that's why he needs vacations.
He needs vacations from his emotions.
All the stress and anxiety, maybe?
You know, now that FUWAMOCO's having a bit of fun with the Ruffians!
Maybe.
But this kind of Pero's still kind of working hard.
Is he?
Yeah.
Does he know that?
How to work hard?
It's good that we got an update from Pero, huh?
Don't be that excited, okay, Ruffians?
It's just Pero.
Who do you like better, Ruffians?
Pero or FUWAMOCO?
Huh?
Ruffians.
Moco-chan, I guess we should continue.
A Doggie of the Day.
These doggies of the day haven't done anything wrong!
There are two doggies today in Hachien City!
They're very cute.
I'm not happy, but they're very, very cute.
Wait, Moco-chan.
What?
We have a challenge to do!
I don't know what you're talking about.
Ruffians don't remember.
It's a birthday!
It's a new week, and that means Moco-chan is going to be challenging herself to eat some more natto!
Moco-chan.
Trying to be tricky.
I'm not.
Well, today Moco-chan will be eating natto once more.
To be honest, Ruffians, I've lost track of how many times Moco-chan has tried this, but... But it's okay because today she's going to show a lot of progress, right?
Right?
For any Ruffians that might not know what natto is, natto is a common breakfast food in Japan.
It's made up of fermented soybeans.
It's really good for you, it's really yummy, but it's kind of sticky, and smelly, and strong smelling, and maybe it's a bit of an acquired taste, but it's yummy and I like it, and it's really healthy for you.
FUWAMOCO-chan.
Do you remember what happened at Anime NYC?
Right.
Right, you made a promise there.
I did.
Right.
To Victoria.
To Victoria, yeah.
And she's going to be doing her best to eat it today too, right?
So, Moco-chan, you have a buddy up there!
This is only for Victoria and not the Ruffians that said they like pale bear, okay?
Not for you.
Moco-chan, make sure you eat as much as you can together with her.
Okay.
Give it!
I'm gonna stir it up!
It needs to be stirred up so it gets nice and fluffy.
Fluffy, fluffy, fluffy, fluffy, fluffy natto.
Was a joke.
Huh?
Not a joke.
Don't spill it.
I almost spilled it everywhere.
It almost got on me.
Not on me.
Okay!
It's ready.
Moco-chan, first.
Let's say thank you to the farmers in Tochigi who worked hard to make it.
I'll say thank you to the farmers in Tochigi, but not to the Ruffians that said they like petal better!
Cheer up, Moco-chan.
It'll all be good once you eat this all with Victoria.
Okay!
That's not the chopsticks I like.
And today, Ruffians, I even offered Moco-chan, do you want to use some soy sauce?
And Moco-chan said, no, I think it'll just make me feel worse.
I don't know, I think you're pretty hungry this morning, right?
Right?
Why are you spooking so sad?
Moco-chan will do it!
You have extra motivation.
I'll do it for Victoria.
Only for Victoria.
Yeah.
Moco-chan, you need to pick up more than just one single solo bean.
I will pick up a solo bean and I will do my best for Victoria.
Victoria wants you to eat more than just one bean.
No, she told me.
She said one.
She told me.
She said one!
Oh, I can hear her right now.
Victory for victory and Victoria!
She's gonna beat you if you're not careful, Moco-chan.
I'm gonna try it, okay.
Okay, do you need a countdown?
No.
Okay!
I need a tissue.
I don't need a countdown, I need a tissue.
Oh wait.
There's my tissue, but... Okay, there's my tissue.
It's just one bean.
It's better than the dry natto, right?
The dry natto was just weird.
The strings, I can see them.
Stop commenting on the strings!
Here we go, here we go, here we go!
Eat!
Why did you not swallow it?
That's how eating works, Moco-chan.
That's how eating works, you just... So wait, Moco-chan, maybe there's a fundamental flaw here in your strategy.
No, I'm trying!
You just put it in your mouth and just let it sit there.
What about Victoria?
I did it for Victoria!
One more.
No.
I'll select a small one just for you.
Look at it.
No.
It's so small.
No!
I'm a small little bean.
No.
Moco-chan.
Doggie of the Day!
I like that much more than Natto.
I like the expression.
She's like... I don't like Natto.
Well, Suri likes to sit on her brother as a sign of affection, and I get that.
I'm not careful, I'm gonna get knocked all over the place here.
Yeah, and apparently Suri also likes to do it all the time.
I think it's pretty cute.
Sometimes it sort of happens when I sit down on the sofa after Fuwawa.
Well, that's what I was gonna ask, Moco-chan.
You know,
I'm not a good princess.
Why?
I think Suri goes like BAU BAU!
And Hachi is also like BAU BAU!
They sound the same.
They're similar.
I don't know.
It sure seems like Suri knows how to get away with being babied.
Maybe a little bit like Moco-chan.
What?! !
And that's okay, Moco-chan, you know?
I'll be your Hachi if you need me to be.
You'll be my Hachi?
Yeah.
I'm fluffy, you know?
I can be the comfy pillow, maybe.
But... Yeah.
I think, you know, Hachi doesn't mind either for his sister, so... Yeah.
They're good doggies.
I like them.
A wonderful family.
BAU BAU!
Today I went on a walk.
Where did we go for a walk this time?
It's like rain.
Tense weather.
It looks so cool though.
But you didn't get rained on or anything, right?
Did you miss the rain?
Hopefully.
I don't really like the rain, but the one thing I do like about the rain is the smell of the ground after.
Sometimes, just thinking about it, you know, it can awaken something in us.
So it's really annoying me.
All right.
Well, you know, we hope you can avoid the rain while going on some more nice walks, too.
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Those buildings are really tall, though, right?
What do we have for our Question of the Day?
We have... De-den!
Hi, FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
Did you know that dogs commonly get ear infections?
Does FUWAMOCO clean their ears often, check each other's, and put in ear drops?
Should you guys like doctors and probably touch your ears for health?
I hope FUWAMOCO is staying healthy.
Well, don't touch each other's ears.
No.
But ear infections...
Ear infections.
They hurt.
They hurt, right.
It's important to take care of yourself.
But, it's important to take care of your ears.
Clean your ears, okay?
But especially since our headphones make our demon dog ears feel a bit funny.
We have to wear them for a long period of time.
Yeah, it gets a bit funny, but... Actually, I used to have troubles with ear infections and had to see the ear doctor quite a bit.
It was really bad, but one time they were looking in my ear to see if they could see anything like a hole in the eardrum.
They couldn't find it for the life of them.
It wasn't good.
Yeah, until they realized they were looking through it.
Through the hole.
You know, that was a long, long time ago and it hasn't been a problem for many dog years.
Not good though, huh?
Yeah, but ear drops aren't fun.
Eye drops aren't fun.
Being sick, it's not fun.
It's important to stay healthy, okay?
Let's make sure to stay healthy, okay, Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
Thank you again so much for all your submissions, Ruffians!
It's nice to know that we got a bit of an update from Pero there, right?
I wish he would not be on vacation.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Let's take a look at our next theme!
We have Metal Gear Solid!
For today, you know, we're gonna be off and we're gonna be resting up and getting a bunch of homework done, but tomorrow we're playing Metal Gear Solid again!
You know, we had a bunch of fun last week as we just started it.
I'm looking forward to see what happens next.
Yeah, now we have our PS1 memory card too.
Yeah.
No worrying.
No worrying about saving, but we're gonna make sure to save a lot.
Yes.
Definitely, Moco-chan, you'll be doing that because you like to save a lot.
I like to save.
Yeah, well let's do our best to sneak, sneak, sneak!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
Our brand new schedule!
This week, this weekend!
It's twin day on the 25th!
Eifutago no hi!
So we're gonna be celebrating it with a collab all about twins together with Rui-nee-san for the first time!
We'll also be releasing a new FUWAMOCO cover song after it and then having an after party!
After that.
After it and after party.
After party, yeah.
You know, but we hope that you know that every song cover is really important to us and special to us.
We hope you'll be there.
Yeah, we put a lot of work into it, so we hope that you'll listen and be there on that release.
Okay.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for joining us today for our 46th FUWAMOCO Morning!
That's right, 46.
Rosso!
BAU BAU!
Tentai!
Viva!
BAU BAU!
Ametoid!
Simplecure!
BAU BAU!
Tonight Solid!
Shoumachi!
BAU BAU!
V40!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
You like FUWAMOCO better, right?
Right, Ruffians?